et maintenant j'accueille gaspard proust
pour elle est pas belle la vie
[Musique]
alors une pensée émue pour cet
automobiliste se naufragés de la route
coincés avec deux enfants et qu'on a pu
sauver et oui la france est en crise
faute de moyens pour s'acheter un frigo
les gens sont réduits à profiter de la
météo pour tenter d'assassiner leurs
mioches
oui car le drame majeur de la semaine
c'est de l'eau de l'eau gelée dieu trop
occupé à se choisir un délégué terrestre
a par inadvertance mis la france aux
congés elle résultats
politiquement conséquences redoutables
mercredi alors qu'il avait arrêté de
neiger depuis 24 heures jean marc
ayrault prévoyait face à la neige et au
verglas
encore 48 heures difficiles
pour jean-marc encore un peu il nous
donnera les coefficients des marées les
risques d'avalanche et l'horoscope
héros qui appelle à la patience et à la
vigilance mais je je je je je non je
n'en peux plus pourquoi dans ce pays à
chaque fois qu'il ya un nuage un peu
chargé qui passe j'ai l'impression
d'être en maternelle je ne retiens c'est
genre truc qui me donne envie d'être
premier ministre tu vois moi premier
mini je vois le blizzard qui arrive
balance à la france entière demain
verglas et de chutes de neige surtout
n'oubliez pas vos tongs et vous paraît
au tas de débile
alors que les mecs qui font une cellule
de crise la war room consacrés au brésil
et au verglas fatwa avec hollande qui
promet des mesures exceptionnelles en
temps de crise on arrive à trouver
exceptionnel le déploiement d'une
pelleteuse et d'un chasse neige
alors c'est que le début un jeu sans que
hollande va jouer les gros bras contre
l'acharnement météorologiques vivement
qu'ils montrent les crocs face à la
canicule contre le temps qui passe le
saignement des gencives quand on se
brosse les dents enfin toner moi
personnellement j'aime beaucoup les
catastrophes météorologiques parce que
sans catastrophe météorologique or et
ont la chance de voir passer dans les
yeux de delahousse la menace soudaine
que représente pour lui laurent romejko
pendant ce temps-là 1800 km c'est
étrange rassemblement de des milliers de
personnes se sont réunies place saint
pierre pour s'extasier devant un pot
d'échappement braqués vers le ciel
ça c'est la force de la religion
catholique incréé de la ferveur grâce à
l'évaporation d'un mari
cerveau ce que ça vaut même peu de
galéjades le tandem tombe bien sûr mes
amis alors bon moi j'étais très inquiet
deux fois la fumée noire ouf la fumée
blanche le pape et blanc
non
[Applaudissements]
non non mais je dis ça c'est pas un pape
noir s'est pas encore possible l'église
n'est pas encore prête pour avoir un
pape et heroes
vous
alors je dis ça beaucoup de catholiques
vont dire que c'est complètement gratuit
c'est vrai
mais dieu est amour et dieu même donc
faites pas chier dessus
non mais c'est vrai que c'est très
pénible ce procès en pédophilie
permanents ont jugé au lieu de
comprendre la pédophilie existe
peut-être mais n'est-ce pas d'abord un
résultat de l'environnement avez vous
déjà vu le plafond de la chapelle
sixtine les seul mec à poil c'est des
anges
alors le pape s'appelle your guemari
oberoi au 1 c'est le premier pape avec
un nom d'avant centre du barça
[Applaudissements]
je dis tout ça évidemment j'aime
beaucoup le pape c'est comme le digne
successeur du surréalisme c'est le seul
type au monde qui est capable de se
promener au milieu des guerres de la
misère et de la souffrance tout en
disant je vous annonce une bonne
nouvelle je christ et joie ouais
peu près autant d'intérêt que traiter un
cancer et aux huiles essentielles
m'enfin passons
internationale à shanghai et des
milliers de cochons morts sont repêchés
au fil du fleuve après vérification il
s'agirait de la livraison katende findus
pour ses boîtes de vote pour lui
[Applaudissements]
restons dans le comestibles si vous le
voulez bien alors c'est peut-être de
l'intox voire du botox les condamnés
chinois exécuté se retrouvent dans des
crèmes un décret pour la wii oui bon
d'habitude on met de la baleine et du
phoque pour une fois qu'on recycle les
vrais coupables
eux au moins ils ont une vraie politique
de répression
lyon à la ville parle pas l'animal qui
fait miaou bien sûr lyon
un homme qui jettent de l'acide sur
trois prostituées c'est quand même
terrible les ravages de la malbouffe sur
la qualité du sperme
[Applaudissements]
tu as compris le truc
saskia
[Musique]
culture
culture donc télévision je trouve que
la qualité des programmes télé a
fortement augmenté je suis tombé sur
confessions intimes enfin un
documentaire qui vous réconcilie avec
l'idée qu'il faudrait donner des
allocations familiales en priorité aux
familles qui décident de ne pas avoir
d'enfant
mais tu es méchant à votre service une
bonne nouvelle peut être le figaro nous
apprend que le tourisme en syrie s'est
effondré maintenant plus aucune excuse
pour ne pas aller aux seychelles alors
elle est pas belle la vie et pour être
sûr de ne rien rater de zinal antitube
abonnez vous il m'était impossible eux